my hope would be that WB goes to
Avalanche and says what do you guys want
to make everything he said is the exact
opposite of what I would do you don't
need multiplayer to extend the life of a
game if you tally the community I think
most would prefer to keep it as a single
player game and oh my gosh Jam that is
you're right that is the worst that's
the worst case scenario I think
introducing those elements of live
service could alienate a lot of people
yo that is the idea I have heard long
time Avalanche software had never
attempted a game on the scale of
Hogwarts Legacy and yet the game has
already made over a billion dollars a
number that certainly only increased
since the last official update in May
Legacy has been widely praised by fans
and critics alike with many believing it
laid the groundwork for an even bigger
and better sequel unfortunately internet
rumors new hires and even comments from
the man on top of the entire company
have fans concerned WB discovered CEO
recently told investors their focus is
to transform some of their biggest
franchises to quote include more always
on gameplay through live services
multiplatform and free-to-play
extensions with the goal to have more
players spending more time on more
platforms is Avalanche software getting
ready to go the way of rock steady the
once beloved Studio behind the Batman
Arkham games so when this news first
broke I thought about doing a news
update video which I could have done
however I really wanted to do this one
Justice I wanted to really get into the
Nuance here and so I decided to bring on
a special guest my friend and fellow
YouTuber James of expecto go is one of
the biggest Potter fans on the internet
his passion and dedication to The
Wizarding World Community even caught
the eyes of avalanche software as he was
given the opportunity to meet with many
of the devs and a behind the-scenes look
at the studio he then helped show a bit
more of Hogwarts Legacy to the world in
the first ever gameplay showcase now
like our channel here James has covered
hogwart's Legacy and The Wizarding World
fandom extensively so who better to have
a conversation with not only about the
future of Hogwarts Legacy but the future
of Wizarding World video games as a
whole I saw this tweet from you which
you and I I mean we're pretty positive
people right we're we keep it real but
we try to keep things positive we have a
good outlook on things so when I saw
even you Tweeting about this saying hold
up I knew I had to have a deeper
conversation with you here to to dive
into this so here's your Tweet and I'll
pop it on screen for people but you said
I'm GNA be honest this is a Straight
Cash grab IMO there's nothing about one
storytelling two player experience three
building trust and brand and mentioning
biggest franchises and monetary has me
worried about the future of Wizarding
World Games primarily Hogwarts Legacy
well you have a game um developed by
Avalanche software that has four
however reasons has just won over a lot
of people so much so that it's made over
a billion dollars in just a couple of
months and as of we're recording now
probably a little bit more over there
especially after the release of the
Nintendo switch versions of the game so
if they are focusing on monetary gains
why would you affect a franchise which
they have in the quote from Z live like
Hogwarts Legacy which wb's uh I think
president David haad had confirmed back
in March that we want to turn hogwart's
Legacy into a franchise right right why
are you trying to get more
money after it just gave you a billion
dollars so he's talking to the investors
like Hey we're gonna try and make more
money so invest in us more so he's
trying to convince these guys who have
invested in WB Discovery I get it but at
the same time as
I don't think zaslav um has any uh read
on why Hogwarts Legacy and some of the
other franchises were successful and I
don't think the live service route Akins
to that or even helps with that uh
thought process especially after just
seeing again what hogo Lees was able to
do in just just a couple of months with
making over a billion dollars so um felt
to me more as like we want to make more
money a cash grab and there's nothing
about telling good stories connecting
with the community yo heck making sure
we get brand trust because he's only
been CEO for a little bit over a year
nothing about that and so it just sounds
like again a cash grab and we want to uh
assure the investors we're going to make
more money so you should invest in WB uh
discover even more and I I was just
yeah and to be clear he doesn't mention
Hogwarts Legacy specifically right but
you and I and many others I think are
connecting the dots here when you say
biggest franchises and you look up their
past year I mean nothing's been bigger
for them than Hogwarts Legacy we know
they've got the TV show in the works
which even that is kind of a cash grab
been a bit of a hit or miss with fans
you know some fans are like what and I
mean even you and I who are optimistic
were're like okay we I'll definitely
watch it I'm curious to see but if you
pulled every Harry Potter fan and said
what would you like to see I don't think
that would been top of the list of
remake the original movies I'll be
honest ever since the release of the
last movie deathly H part two it really
feels like The Wizarding World has been
kind of searching for that next thing
right yes and they've been struggling to
find it everybody loves the theme park
the theme parks are great but other than
that it's been a lot of misses the games
I know a game that's very near and dear
to your heart Harry Potter Wizards unite
you loved it that was cancelled uh
didn't make enough money and so it's
like they've been looking for that next
big thing and now you and I think
they've got it I mean they have it they
do they've got it in Hogwarts Legacy and
so yeah when when a quote like this hits
you and I certainly don't represent the
entire fan base but we've been very
plugged into it yeah pretty much the
whole time this game has been in
development and I think we have a good
read on what a lot of fans want for me
like for my perspective Avalanche
software you gave them a chance right
they' never done anything this big you
gave them a chance and by I'm not going
to say all but by most accounts they
knocked it out of the park at least to
the point where you know I mean if you
think about a business and you give this
new employee you're like okay here's a
project for you this is a big project
let's see how you do and they turn in
over a billion
dollars I'm not gonna go and say all
right now here's what I want you do I'm
gonna say you you take this you guys
want to do how can we help y exactly so
that's my hope and I know you've you've
met and talked with a lot of these folks
at Avalanche firsthand you've seen the
passion firsthand yeah so my hope would
be that WB goes to Avalanche and says
and well given this time I hope they
already done this and says right what do
you guys want to make yeah and agree my
hunch I don't know this for sure but I
don't think Avalanche would say we want
to do live Services we wna we want to do
free-to-play stuff we want to do tons of
multiplayer MMO type May Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe they do let's not forget this is
their first step into Triple A open
world type game so why also take another
step into something different when
you're just getting your feet wet
feet wet with this type of game making
process and stuff and let's I mean let's
just be clear it's not just Hogwarts
Legacy or Harry Potter fans who took
this quote kind of off-putting it was
others the biggest skeptic Luke stens
agreed with this by saying everything he
said is the exact opposite of what I
would do you know other content creators
and journalist
are saying the same thing at least along
the lines of this doesn't sound like a
good idea at least just from the outside
looking in and with the quote obviously
we don't know what they have planned it
could be talking about an entirely
different Wizarding World game not so
much Hogwarts Legacy which again we will
get into but we just want to make it
clear it's not just Hogwarts Legacy fans
or Harry Potter fans who were kind of
disgruntled by the quote it was Gamers
alike as well who respect what avalan
software was able to do with Hogwart
Legacy and the success it had being a
single player open world RPG this is a
thing for the broader gaming industry
right now this whole live service thing
and I feel like from my from where I'm
sitting it feels like fortnite may have
been fortnite that pubg era when they
were first kind of that feels like the
thing that really shifted the industry
rocket leagues another one to think like
whoa you're telling me we can make this
kind of money if we just build one game
and consistently update it Destiny's
another one I mean I guess world of
warcraft's been kind of doing it for
years but I feel like fortnite's really
the one the free-to-play model
especially yeah and so you've even seen
this with Sony right now I mean Jim Ryan
stepped down we don't maybe it was just
a retirement but a lot of people seem to
think there was something going on with
I mean he was making a big live service
push for them in their games and I think
every sing one of them has gotten
delayed let's take this quote here and
let's let's say best case scenario you
know what would we like to see sort of
in a perfect world for the future of
Hogwarts Legacy knowing what you do
about Avalanche James and knowing how
they did with this game uh because I
think it it was it's not a perfect game
but it is it is I think a perfect
beginning for them to take and just
absolutely fulfill all the wildest
dreams in the sequel and to see them not
have that chance would hurt if I had
like my choice I wouldn't have live
service at all I would I wouldn't it in
hogw Legacy in hogw Legacy if I had my
choice I would not add any live service
element to Hogwarts Legacy I would keep
it the same recipe that they had just
add more in-game content outside once
you're done with the game okay what are
we going to do now because that has been
a critique for a lot of people they were
like I it was amazing I enjoyed it Bing
Bang Boom I'm done what now and so yeah
if you're a platinum trophy Hunter like
retro over here you can go and kind of
play um other houses and kind of knock
out uh the quest and tasks and
achievements you know to get that
platinum trophy but outside of that it's
really not that much for the gamers I
think they want more stuff to do maybe a
harder challenge maybe add a game plus
situation but I think more so than
anything just extend the current the
life span of the sequel once it comes
out by having a game plus mode or
something else that we can do once we
beat the game yeah yeah I I think I mean
I've said so many times I think one of
the most impressive things about this
about the success of Hogwarts Legacy is
how Harry Potter Phantom is so huge and
they even touch TCH people who were
outside the Phantom with this game and
somehow managed to create a game that
still appealed to the majority of those
people now we all have our critiques and
things that we would have changed and
but by and large it seems like it at
least resonated on some level with
millions of people millions of people
yeah so like you said clearly there was
there was something there that they got
right and I can only imagine all the
things that were had to be left on the
Cutting Room floor we've seen some of
this in the game files of things that
they clearly wanted to do and probably
ran out of time or it didn't quite work
and they had to cut it so that's why I
would love to see them just given free
reign with a sequel for them I I TR
basically I trust Avalanche at this
point I trust them if they were given
the full control and they think that
they can incorporate multiplayer
elements and that it would work right go
for it but right just purely as
a as a grab like you said just to keep
people playing the game yeah that's not
what I want to see because there are so
many other ways that you can make a game
that people talk about years later I
mean people are still talking about
Skyrim they're still talking about Red
Dead 2 the the single player side of Red
Dead 2 yeah and you know I realize I'm
talking about some major top tier
developers right there but right with
avalanche now having this under their
belt
they're going to have the resources to
ex together that kind of that caliber of
a game that a billion dollars people
remember that yeah saying that number so
it's like there's so many possibilities
for what they can do it's like any
business right if do you take that money
and do you blow it on things you
shouldn't or do you reinvest it in the
company in the business so it can make
you more money yeah overall I think
you're exactly right let Avalanche do
what they've been able to do Avalanche
software has a team of people who are
passionate not about just storytelling
not just about gaming but about the IP
they are passionate and care about
making sure they handle it and give it
to those of us who are fans of the IP
but taking care of it where it doesn't
ruin what we fell in love with its IP in
the first place so yeah um having those
people especially at the top down that
enthusiasm that care and that Um passion
I think just you're in good hands just
let them take care of it and do what
they need to do you have a community
manager who knows um the community and
has does a great job listening to what
we as a community would like to see in
future installments so um it's all about
just letting Avalanche software do what
they've been able to do these past
couple of years leading to Hogwarts
Legacy and see it through to the second
one yeah you touched on a great point
there you you don't need multiplayer to
extend the life of a game there are
other ways you can do it and I mean I
look at at I think one of the greatest
recent examples of like DLC is you look
at The Witcher games I mean the the
twostory I didn't even play all of them
but I just played a little bit of them
and from hearing how everybody talked
about them I mean it was almost like
it's its own game you know they already
had this world built and then they just
released all these additional story
quests in this DLC so I think you're
spot on there in a sequel if they were
able to build out a a deeper richer
world around all the main quests that
you're doing to where people do want to
go back like Skyrim and re-experience
things and see things if you go at it
from a different perspective and if
choices were to actually matter if you
have branching asss and all that sort of
thing then you have story de dlc's that
you release on top of it people will
keep your game and people will continue
to spend money on the game when you drop
those so you don't even have to have
multiplayer if you want to keep making
money off of it and you don't have to
build an entirely new game like right
you just add more sections to it it's
already there yeah I think that's the
it's it's just a smart way of doing it
and again you said it so eloquently you
don't need multiplayer to expand this
game so now let's expand it back a bit
because as I alluded to earlier you've
you've played other games in the
Wizarding World you and I are both
ambassadors for Harry Potter magic
awaken which is very underrated in my
opinion I wish more would give it a shot
yes a lot of microtransactions yes it's
mobile yeah that game is really good
yeah so do you think all right expanding
outside of Hogwarts Legacy would you
like to see an MMO set in The Wizarding
World that is you know developed more
from the ground up as a console PC
release yes please and thank
you the wisting world I it's a k to load
of the Rings The Wizarding World is
perfect for absolutely it is perfect um
I I actually have the book here we were
talking about it in a past stream so uh
the Fantastic beast and where to find
them obviously it isn't written uh yet
in Hogwarts Legacy timeline but this is
we're not talking about the beasts are
still there the beasts are still a thing
and uh the ministry of magic has
classified the beasts from one to five
stars with the five star being the
highest and toughest Beast to take down
bro can you imagine me retro Lynette
Andy Ben uh Joe uh Miranda like all of
us coming together and trying to take
down uh a perivan vipertooth or um
whatever think Monster Hunter when you
were talking about that I Monster Hunter
Vibes yes yes yeah there's so many
Avenues not even talking about potion
making not even talking about ways to
travel like a broom and everything like
it's literally World of Warcraft Just
with heck Wizards it's all wizards it's
honestly stunning to me it hasn't been
tried yet I mean I know it's a big task
it's hard to do so I totally agree with
like yeah I totally agree with you again
um like I don't want it to be some
tacked on thing to Hogwarts Legacy I
think it could be
if you do it right from the ground up
and really you know study those other
games that have been doing it right for
a number of years that have Goodwill
with fans and not the games that you
know annoy people with too many
microtransactions because there I mean
there are plenty of good examples out
there now of games that that do it right
for years people have talked about
wanting to be able to uh do their
Wizarding World profession like I want
to be able to use like my profession
which you kind of do a little bit in
Wizards unite I understand right
youth yep yep yeah they had um that
those elements within Wizards unite
where you could be a professor or or
magic zoologist those were like the big
three um professions and skill trees you
could build up based on the profession
you chose so yeah it's there it's there
and like
imagine imagine retro you can let's say
you want to have a profession and stuff
well those professions usually are under
governments so now we got the ministry
of magic we got the makusa over in
United States you can go to different
Brazilian you know Chinese like all
these different governments and heck we
can even do because everybody loves
being in school you could do the wide
variety of wisting schools as factions
and stuff while taking that like it's
all there we're just scratching to the
surface we neily have to be a student
you could be yeah you could be graduated
yeah I totally agree I think there's
definitely a place for a Wizarding World
MMO and more and more rumors seem to be
popping up that it's in the works I
think what's unclear right now is is are
they trying to morph hogwart's Legacy
into this or is it it own thing yeah
that is a big question yeah because um
shout out to uh support Crow Joe Mack
with uh the initial scoop on on uh job
listings under the WB Games
for um a position that has has to have
some live service experience uh when it
comes to uh this job posting I believe
is with under evalan software I know
just based in Utah is why
we're Avalanche yeah okay okay which is
what I I should have mentioned that in
the opening because that does kind of
lead more into the you know we've got
this new quote now from the CEO and then
we also have this evidence that they're
hiring somebody in Utah yeah yeah or I
think it's executive producer yeah but
with live service experience let's say
we don't get our best case scenario
James let's say the CEO came down to
Avalanche and was like you're putting
live service in how can they incorporate
it in a way that will work that will
still please both sides it's because you
and I have seen I mean what is the
percentage of people who want
multiplayer and the people who don't
because I would get so many comments and
I know you did too people saying please
do not put multiplayer I'm a single
player if they put multiplayer I'm not
buying this and then I had just as many
people saying there's nothing left to do
I can't believe I can't even talk with
my friends we got these people on the PC
mods making it so they can all walk
around together in hogw Legacy I'm like
yikes I actually don't know what
what the right choices here and it it
was funny because I had the like you
said we had the exact like sentiment in
our comment sections with our videos but
it was pregame launch and then postgame
launch with hey I don't want anybody to
interact with before the game I need
somebody to talk to after the game's
release so I mean we're we're fans fans
are short for Fanatics you know we're
fickle bunch and uh you know we kind of
go crazy and go with the tide when it
comes to things we're passionate about
but um yeah it was it was divisive and
honestly I was just surprised by the Ric
even before the game and after the game
but I still just getting the vibe based
off of um the conversations we've been
having with this topic as of late a lot
of people are still like the game was
still so good despite it not having
having enough stuff after beating the
game they still enjoyed the single
player aspect and I think they're more
fearful of corporate or higher-ups
interfering with the game that they've
enjoyed at least the aspect that they
enjoyed so I think most if you tall the
community I think most would prefer to
keep it as a single player game that
being said I did throw in uh suggest
like I said earlier that goes to sushima
Route uh with uh like dungeon crawling
or battle arena type situations I think
just the overall
fear with WB and zaz's comments is just
interfering with what work it could work
out but more likely it could turn the
fan base off but um if I have to answer
the question and have to have something
in there based off what Zas laugh is
implementing as a company policy yeah um
I would just say go the game go to
sushima Route talk to them see how they
implemented it ex and keep it simple
while still giving you the option of
keeping it single player that's that's
me we're agreeing a lot today but you
and I think the same on a lot of things
but yeah I think if you can clearly
separate it because that that was what
was so I mean the ghost of tsushima
thing kind of dropped out of nowhere
nobody knew
yeah people were already loving the
single player and talked about how great
of a game it was and they like oh yeah
if you want to group up with some
friends here's this multiplayer mode
that was actually pretty good it was and
I even think back to I mean it's not the
best example right now but the original
Last of Us factions was something that
nobody like that was a it just happened
to be in the game they had this
multiplayer mode that actually was
pretty good now they're trying to make
it its own separate thing which they're
having trouble with but the last of us
one of the greatest my favorite single
player game of all time one of just an
incredible story in video games and then
you have this multiplayer mode so they
even they had a a mode there to keep
people coming back and playing and
interested and let's not forget like if
it could be talking about the Harry
Potter franchise when he references
franchises and stuff so we mention MMO
but we also have quiddit champions for
sure out and we don't know it hasn't
been confirmed yet if it's going to be
live services or not but that looks like
a game that could have even Esports um
aspects to it if it gets competitive
enough and that could be a live service
game as well and we also have Suicide
Squad um kill the Justice League coming
out as well which looks to be a live
service game so right which is under a
lot of heat from what I understand it
looks bad that's Rock Steady right
that's Rock steady that gave us the
Arkham
series that's so baffling to me and
that's the I think that's the worst case
scenario right because they're not a
live service company they never have
been I just pulled up to see if they had
released any other games that i' had
forgotten about they had a Batman Arkham
VR in 2016 but no they had the three
Batman Arkham games which were
universally praised people love them yep
and now they're work working on a live
Ser oh my gosh J that is you're right
that is the wor that's the worst case
scenario because you're turning you
heard Rocksteady was doing something
you're like they're G to do more within
the franchise and stuff we're going to
get another Arkham Trilogy or something
else within it and yeah we're within the
DC you know Batman Universe but it's a
live oh I'm sad why would you take what
they do so well and ibe they I don't
know enough about the studio maybe they
wanted to do something different right I
don't think Avalanche will Avalanche
please but that just like looking at it
here looking at the wik
Wikipedia it's mindblowing that they
went away from the success of Arkham
Asylum Arkham City Arkham Knight and now
you're putting them on who knows maybe
it will release and people will love it
but from what I've seen people are not
enthused about what has been shown so
far uh because I think they did like a
little early access thing or something
where well they did they showed some gam
playay and they showed some aspects of
each of the characters because I believe
there's four characters will be able to
control within the game
and it didn't go well it
did it was not what we see doesn't look
good A lot of people wasn't expecting
loot boxes like all of these aspects
that they're just starting to show just
is going to be a major turnoff and my
thing is especially with this being the
worst case scenario now put that with
Avalanche software in the studio
interference from WB Games what you
would also alienate not just the gamers
but the Harry Potter fans who aren't
Gamers the Potter collector is a prime
example went out bought
bought a PS5 and learned how to stream
just to play this game because it was a
dream come true for potterheads the
thing is live service type games like a
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
that kind of borrows their uh blueprint
from fortnite which I mean fortnite is
amazing is I think it had like 44
million playing at the same time when
the OG map dropped whatever stuff yeah
yeah so everybody wants to duplicate
that which I totally get but again
understanding the player base especially
for the wising world a lot of Harry
Potter fans aren't Gamers and so now you
have to pull in Harry Potter fans to
play games and convince Gamers that this
IP is worthy of your attention to play
in the first place so I think
introducing those elements of live
service could alienate a lot of people
whereas with a single player action RPG
it's isolated is simple hey experience
the story with telling and see how you
feel afterwards and I just
think if they go The Suicide Squad
killer Justice League route is going to
have that reception and really in my
opinion for a is g to have that retion
my wife does not play video games and
even she has said I want to play
Hogwarts Legacy at some point we have
two kids so she hasn't found the time
yet right but even she and she's a nurse
and she works with other nurses who like
Potter collector they bought their
system to play Hogwarts Legacy and we we
kind of heard that early on but I think
even I underestimated just how many
people out there were doing that I mean
anytime I mention that in a video
somebody will comment and say hey that's
me too yep every time so I think yeah
you're spot on and you touched on uh
quiddit Champions a bit too yeah I I
definitely from what what they've the
way they've talked about that game it
definitely feels like it could be like
sort of in that rocket League vein of
like free to play great example these
other things added on who knows how it
will be received once it's finally out I
really do feel like they have the
opportunity to do something unique
because they had like right now you have
all these feels like everything's
disjointed like you've got you tried
Wizards unite you've got puzzles and
spells which apparently he doing pretty
well you got magic awakened you got hog
W's Legacy you're going to have quiddit
Champions maybe there's an MMO coming
it's like is there not some way that we
can I don't know like connect all these
a little bit better I don't know what it
would look like but I oh my gosh
so I'm about to go OG let's hear it
let's hear it so um the first game under
the portkey games uh label Port key
games is what ties wasn't that point of
Porky yes yeah Porky games allows WB
Games to tell their own Wizarding World
stories and not have to worry about it
being Canon so the pory games label I
called was the pgu the pory games
Universe okay so their first game was
Hogwarts mystery that's the one they
tried out I believe they came out in 201
I think that was still out it's still
it's still out it's still out they had a
huge expansion uh last year where you
graduate from Hogwarts and you actually
working and living life by yourself
andow have whizzing World jobs and stuff
on a mobile game by the way so that's
pretty that's what we want in the
console game but anyway so the first one
was U Hogwarts mystery and then they
followed it up with Wizards unite like a
year or two after that the Wizards unite
came out in
2019 following the story in both of
those games because if you're doing a
wizzing world game you have to have a
good story that's where Drew us all into
this world in the first place we started
seeing similarities within both of the
stories particularly a covert uh
operation or uh dark Wizards group
called R in uh hog Mysteries but the
unforgivables or the unspeakables I
can't remember how they were called in
Wizards unite then we started seeing
even more similarities and callbacks to
stuff that I had noticed in um magic
awakened and I tried to see if I could
find some stuff when it came to hogw
Legacy particularly with ancient Magic
because each of them has like a
calamitous type situation that's going
or you have dark Wizards looking for
this ancient type magic in eng wizard
unite a certain ancient magic that
hasn't been touched on was used which um
I guess resulted in the foundable spell
and everything like that so there's been
hints to or at least nods to the other
games within a certain game so Wizards
unite would nod to Hogwart mystery and
so forth and so on and I think you're
hitting it right on thee you can create
your own little universe and have them
all tie in at least just from a
storytelling standpoint kind of
promoting these other games as well as
selling different types of games that
people can get into within the wising
world or Port key games label so I'm I'm
all for that and I think they have been
doing that it's just just whether you
build upon it and go with it or just
keep throwing different types of games
out there and see what sticks right yeah
it feels more like that which I mean
there has to be some degree of that with
anything right you got to see what
resonates and you don't always know
going into it I can't describe it
because I don't know what it looks like
it's never been done before but if they
got a lot of smart people there that fig
this out because I know what you're
talking about everybody wanted quiditch
in Hogwarts Legacy right yeah yeah and
yet we're getting quidditch Champions
but there's a huge chunk of Hogwarts
Legacy people who won't who will never
touch it no matter because certain way
yeah y it's like if there was some way
like if I was playing Hogwarts Legacy
and I'm like I go to the Quidditch pitch
and it's like oh do you want to play
Quidditch and then you la you're in
quidditch Champions all of a sudden it
be jarring if it looked different but it
would be it would talking like perfect
world if it it was the same graphics and
everything you know they have to capture
the magic oh a lot of the a lot of and
what I mean by that is we want to be
Harry Potter we want you get even a
casual person a w yeah we we want our
own story we want to live within the
wising world and experienced it for the
first time yes we were able to do that
with hogart Legacy and even even other
uh Harry Potter games but Hogwarts
Legacy was the first one where it was
our story and it was as immersive as it
was that's why it made as much money
what ties everything together as Alan 2
said was Hogwarts was that experience of
attending Hogwarts as a student and
experiencing the wising world through
that lens and then expanding upon that
and so I think you start at Hogwarts
Legacy and then you expand two
professions as a grownup working as an
aura in the ministry and doing a have
that be a separate game and then you
have Little Kitty games for kids for all
ages well not so much all ages but a
certain youth type game where kids can
uh do our new and Friends idea where
it's Pokemon but with news Commander
who's saving uh Beast going out and you
know CT
Fantastic Beasts around the world as a
kitty game I think if you have
t it sounds like what you're describing
there just a little
bit Yeah but we W get into that but I
think having because that that age that
age range is so broad right now yeah
because we both what makes Park so fun
too because like everybody's experien
yep yep yep so I think if you start
having games that are as immersive like
a Hogwarts Legacy but for different type
of fans who want to see what happens
after school who want to just be in
school or who just getting into the
world for the first time I think if you
knock out those three fandoms within the
Harry Potter IP then knock it out the
park because you're going to solidify
those hardcore Harry Potter fans now
worri about the gaming aspect to bring
in the gamers I think you have something
there to work with and have its own
storyline see-through line where it's
all connected because you start out
young now you're at Hogwarts and now
you've graduated and you're an A or
working in the ministry or uh whatever
other profession you want to do heck go
back as a teacher and uh teach back at
Hogwarts so I think if they think about
what a wisting world or Harry Potter fan
would want to
experience and go off of that while
pleasing Gamers with the technical
aspects of it that would bring them in I
think you have something that could be
successful and cohesive at the same time
dude you know what would sell incredibly
well if they I wouldn't want this to
replace Hogwarts Legacy 2 or whatever
they call the next game but imagine if
Avalanche could have take that billion
dollars make a second team and they like
remake that is where I would love to see
a remake if we got a remake of The Seven
book series oh my gosh by Avalanche
software yeah you built yeah yeah you're
printing money now you
got because I love those games man but
those games were made so long ago those
games were made under big time crunch to
where they were trying to hit movie
releases
Retro Retro CU it's like they've got the
spellcasting system right you've got the
got the castle those are two of the most
important things who wouldn't want
professor mcgo as a teacher who wouldn't
want snake to see Avalanche get a chance
to like make their version
of unreal Chamber of Secrets whoa bro yo
that is the best idea I have heard the
long time and I hate remakes outside of
Final Fantasy I hate remakes but bro
let's do it come on aval it happen aval
software second team let's go yeah
because I wouldn't I wouldn't want it to
take the place of a new story but right
right right I mean it's one thing to
remake the movies which are still not
even that old but those games the
technology in video games has just go
back people look up if you if you go to
YouTube and look up the complete history
of Harry Potter video games you might
find a video made by somebody this guy
and you could take a look at what those
first games look like heck even your
Let's Plays like yeah oh my gosh so to
to see those being because a lot of
people say every time I play one of
those games or talk about it people say
I wish they would re-release these and
I'm like I don't know if you really do
what you really want is a complete and
total remake from the ground up with
with news yeah today's graphics and even
today's gameplay stuff because a lot of
the gameplay then it's like what what
are we doing here um so yeah just let
Avalanche completely remake the original
Seven oh my that's what I'm saying
gosh retro that's a
video retro that is genius that it could
make so much money it would make so much
money it would make so much money wait
wait okay release it as the TV show is
coming out yeah yes done yes billion
again it all together and one thing I
can say to you guys for certain about
both WB Games and Avalanche software is
that they absolutely listen to the
community they may always be able to do
exactly what we're hoping for but they
100% do listen so this is your chance
guys sound off in the comments below are
James and I Wrong where do you agree
where do you disagree do you want a
Harry Potter MMO what do you want to see
for Hogwarts Legacy we'd love to hear
from you guys there YouTube Just So Happ
to think that this video would be a
great one for you to check out next as
always guys thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again
[Music]
soon